collet lolo je vous avoue un truc en
fait je vous ai menti les cailloux ça
n'existe pas les géologues n'utilise pas
le terme cailloux on utilise une
ribambelle d'autres mots tous plus
intéressants que les autres les uns que
les autres
pour rendre cette vidéo définition
vachement funky on va le faire sous
forme de jeu pour ça il nous faut un
décor un peu de fastes du tralala
allez c'est parti ah bah ouais c'est
beaucoup mieux un peu de superfétation
j'ai l'impression d'être cendrillon je
vais vous présenter cette émission avec
ma soeur jumelle morte qui s'appelle
fiona bonjour fiona
et comme je suis quelqu'un de très bien
j'ai décidé de vous faire participer à
cette vidéo est donc j'ai laissé un
tweet et un message facebook pour vous
demander comment vous appelleriez un
caillou si vous étiez géologue dieu nous
en garde
vous avez été très nombreux à participer
donc je remercie beaucoup je remercie
aussi tous mais faut qu'on va pouvoir
dépiauter toutes vos réponses en
sanglots à les génériques
[Musique]
defensio cette musique le transporte à
chaque fois
notre première participation c'est une
roche c'est effectivement le terme
qu'utilisent les géologues pour parler
d'un caillou la plupart du temps donc si
vous devez retenir qu'un seul mot
baroque blessures en fait une roche
c'est un agrégat de plein de trucs alors
imaginez ces genres à un cake aux olives
ou les olives seraient des faux cils ou
des minéraux ce genre de truc donc il ya
des éléments qu'on peut voir l'onu et
d'autres qu'on voit pas mais qui donne
du goût alors qu'ils donnent de la
texture donc une roche c'est comme vous
avez dit vous même c'est un assemblage
de minéraux si on connaît exactement la
composition d'une roche on peut
l'appeler par son petit nom par exemple
si ça à cette gueule là et que ça
contient 5 minéraux là bas vous pouvez
l'appeler granit
maintenant vous avez proposé spécimens
ou échantillons que ça ça marche aussi
si vous voulez parler exactement du
caillou que vous tenez dans la main à un
moment précis donc genre ça c'est un
magnifique spécimen de je ne sais pas du
tout mais c'est très beau aucun
échantillon c'est en gros une unité qui
donne une idée du tout par exemple un
échantillon de basalte en l'occurrence
ou de granit ou ce que vous
j'arrête de dire ce que vous voulez tout
le temps si vous voulez avoir l'air snob
en toutes circonstances vous pouvez vous
baissez prendre n'importe quel client
qui est là et dire où cet échantillon a
l'air fort habitants et la participation
suivante nous vient de dav qui nous
parle de ses des minéraux [ __ ] alors
effectivement minéraux ça marche aussi
surtout si vous êtes minéralogie en
minéral c'est ce qu'on appelle un solide
homogène naturel la plupart du temps qui
est caractérisée par un arrangement
cristallin ces atomes qui sont bien
rangés et aussi une composition chimique
déterminées dont par exemple si vous me
dites calcite je vous dis bam caco3 si
vous me dites barritt je vous dis b as
sous quatre mois ben ils sont quatre on
classe les minéraux en fonction de leur
composition chimique donc par exemple
s'ils contiennent du bord on les appelle
des borat ou s'ils contiennent de la
syrie sont les appels des silicates et à
l'intérieur de ces familles là on les
réorganise en fonction de leur structure
atomique par exemple pour les silicates
ceux qui sont faits de chêne d'atomes
qui suivent les uns après les autres ça
on les appelle les néo silicates le
zircon par exemple en fait partie ou
alors je vous avais parlé aussi d'un
dernière vidéo d argile qui sont faites
de feuilles est ce qu'on appelle les
phyllosilicates comme le mit cap
un minerai est très très impressionnant
alors minerai ça c'est quand vous avez
une roche qui est d'intérêt particulier
pour l'homme
donc on peut l'exploiter prenons
l'exemple des baux-de-provence qui se
situe en provence c'est une ville qui
est très riche en bauxite de l'oxydé
d'aluminium qui a été nommé bauxite
parce qu'elle était décrite pour la
première fois dans cette ville
cette bauxite c'est un minerai
d'aluminium et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
est exploité aussi du côté de gardanne
si je vous parle de boue rouge
alors ensuite nous avons une pierre
alors une pierre ça c'est comme kyle
busch c'est pas possible sauf si vous
êtes joaillier alors à ce moment-là ça
marche parce que lé joaillier parle de
pierres précieuses
on parle plus généralement de j'aime les
gmc des minéraux qui sont très très
transparent et très très très pur et
comme ça on peut en faire des bijoux
dans l'eau on a les quatre spice girls
cgem le diamant l'émeraude le rugby et
le saphir c'est les pierres précieuses
en deuxième on m'a les poulidor des gmc
les pierres semi-précieuses qu'on peut
plus appeler comme ça c'est interdit
et donc maintenant les appelle les
pierres fines y en a plein elles sont
aussi elles sont transparentes elles
sont jolies mais montrait des pierres
précieuses quoi sauf qu'en fait non pas
du tout depuis 2002 les appellations
pierres précieuses des pierres fines
disparaissent quand même temps que le
franc dominicaine et mon père parti
chercher des cigarettes
maintenant on est 10 plus que le père
j'aime mais ne le fait pas remarquer
elle a l'air tellement en 3e catégorie
on a les pierres qui sont ornementale
elles sont plus vraiment transparent
d'où qu'elles sont justes translucide ou
alors aux pâquis en a plein plein plein
et aussi des pierres qui sont arnaud
mentale et qui sont d'origine organique
ça veut dire qu'elles sont fabriquées
par des êtres vivants ça je trouve ça
trop lambres par exemple qui est de la
résine d'arbre fossilisée les perles
aussi et le corail rouge tout ça c'est
considérer comme des pierres
ornementales par lé joaillier
mais dis donc c'est l'heure de la
chronique de fiona
[Musique]
merci fiona pour ce regard toujours très
acéré sur le monde qui nous entoure à la
prochaine contribution nous vient d'un
fidèle lecteur du var qui nous parle des
crises post à eau alors un cristal oui
c'est un cristal oui alors les cristaux
c'est comme quand vous avez un genre de
minéralité alou tous les atomes sont
vraiment bien arrangé entre et du coup
ça forme un motif géométrique d'atomes
qui se répètent les uns à côté des
autres et donc ça c'est très étudiée par
les cristallographe et il plonge au
coeur du cristal en fait pour voir
comment l'arrangement de tous ces atomes
entre eux influent sur les propriétés
physico-chimiques du minéral par exemple
la manière dont ils renvoient la lumière
ce genre de choses alors maintenant que
maintenant pardon j'ai un truc sous le
pied ah oui ah oui c'est ça alors on m'a
parlé de gravier main on peut parler
aussi de sable on peut parler de lyme
enfin de plein de choses extraordinaires
si on prend vos céréales de petit
déjeuner lavaud cenal de hipster donc le
musli il ya des gros morceaux il ya des
petites miettes de votre dignité et puis
ya de la poussière le géologue qui peut
s'intéresser plutôt d'essayer
d'identifier chaque chose de regarder
juste la taille des particules et la
proportion relative des uns par rapport
aux autres ça donne plus d'informations
sur plein de choses mais j'en parlerai
dans une autre vidéo pour ça donc il ya
une classification qui existe des plus
grosses particules qui s'appelle des
blocs ou des rochers jusqu'au plus petit
qui s'appelle de l'argile et entre temps
on a du gravier du sable du limon et de
l'argile la blague parce que les
géologues sont des farceurs l'argile
dont je parle maintenant c'est pas la
même que celle dont je vous ai parlé
dans la vidéo précédente par exemple
l'argile des minéralogistes c'est une
composition chimique déterminé c'est
vous savez des feuillets d'atomes avec
de l'eau qui circule entre eux tout ça
donc ça c'est une chose vraiment bien
délimitées là ce que j'appelle l'argile
pour le coup c'est n'importe quoi du
moment que c'est broyer suffisamment
fins par exemple si vous voulez vous
débarrasser d'un cadavre
vous pouvez tout passé au mixeur et si
vous arrivez à avoir des particules de
moins d'un tiers de mm de diamètre et
ben on appelle ça de large et là ce
moment là je vous déconseille de vous
faire un masque avec voilà donc en gros
là on a fait le tour de toutes les
différentes manières d'appeler un
caillou quand on est géologue si vous
êtes jeu en général vous pouvez parler
de roche de spécimens ou d'échantillons
ou alors qu'on vous regardez plus à
l'échelle du paysage vous pouvez parler
de couches géologiques où deux
formations géologiques
après si vous êtes plutôt minéralogiste
vous pouvez parler d'eux
nero de cristaux de pierres précieuses
gemmes de pierres fines et si vous vous
intéressez plus à la taille des
particules comme les jeux aux
morphologies qui s'intéresse plus à
l'histoire des cours d'eau et à comment
il se forme comment ils déposent les
sédiments ce genre de trucs et bien ce
moment-là vous parlerai plutôt de roches
et de blocs de gravier et de sable de
delémont d'argile et si votre truc c'est
plutôt de vendre votre âme aux
industriels pour gagner de la thune des
bains vous vous parlerais plutôt de
minerais ou deux gisements
[Musique]
block matériau minéral proche de gravier
matériaux et roche bloc
il n'ira autres herbes corbeau arbres
seule banque tarneaud un doigt et
jean-phi symbole de la suprématie des
francs-maçons illuminati qui nous
gouvernent dans l'ombre
rageant
[Musique]
alors là on a fini avec tous les termes
génériques mais certains d'entre vous
ont proposé des mots qui n'était pas
pour désigner tous les cailloux mais que
j'ai quand même trouvé intéressant et
dans l'eau j'en ai sélectionné en c'est
le gall est un galet c'est un fragment
de roche ça peut être n'importe quel
rush mais ce qui le caractérise c'est
vraiment qu'il est arrondi il est
vraiment bien 10 comme ça et ça ça vient
de son mode de transport parce que au
départ il a été transporté par un cours
d'eau qui l'a arraché à sa roche mère
c'est une mère qui a perdu ses enfants
c'est vraiment très triste il y va des
vallées absolument tout le cours d'eau
et lova l'abrasion au nez complètement
sur toutes les faces non curat plus
d'angle et il va être complètement rond
et lisse comme un discours de politicien
c'est ce qu'on appelle un galet et ça
peut être de plein de composition
différentes pouvaient avoir des galets
de nice par exemple des galettes calcite
des mathieu gallet fins et très divers
maintenant pardon j'ai un truc sous le
pied ça fait que tu le sors et avant de
nous quitter je donne la réponse à la
question de la semaine dernière si vous
avez bien été attentif la réponse était
le merlu voilà merci de votre attention
merci azéma petit peur qu'ils
regardaient plus pour remplir votre
piscine de pièces de 1 franc le dvd
dominicains et de mon père parti charge
les civils
à mossel
[Musique]
et
ah que quoi
ban à revoir
m
baho mais je sais
la seule
la watch temps
oui
key
[Musique]